We got it right.
Wonderful.
Itamar Novick,  thank you so much
for being on the show.
I really appreciate your time.
Michael, thanks for having me.
I'm super excited to be here.
I am so excited to learn
over these next 20 minute
what it means to scale businesses,
to raise venture capital.
You've raised over $270 million yourself
of venture capital funds,
besides being an early stage investor
through Recursive Ventures
and being a venture partner
of UpWest and Jay Ventures.
And I if I begin to say everything
that you've done,
I'm not gonna end there.
Itamar, give me a brief rundown
of who you are.
What are you passionate about?
And let's move from there.
Absolutely. Thanks for asking.
So, I'm an operating investor,
which means that I have a day job
during the day and that is the
Chief Business Officer at Life360.
A company I helped take public last year
in the Australian Stock Exchange
for a valuation of over 600 US million dollars.
And at night and on weekends,
I'm at Recursive Ventures,
which is a seed fund
that I've raised myself.
And I've been investing in startup companies
at the pre-seeds stage
of the last eight or nine years.
Incredible. Okay.
Hold on, what is chief business officer?
I know what a chief executive officer,
or chief financial officer.
What is the chief business officer?
So, I think it's a little bit
up for interpretation.
Different companies use that title
sparingly for different things,
specifically for Life360.
Being a consumer business,
being a seed business,
I'm really the person that manages most
of the business development opportunities
with different partners.
Creating an ecosystem of partners
and other parties
that want to engage with us.
And also, doing what's called
corporate development,
which is mostly M&A.
And that's us acquiring
potentially smaller companies
and expand our product line
or help with our talents in the company.
Incredible. So, you're moonlighting as
the precedent seed investor,
yet you're running,
you're helping formulate
business propositions and M&As
for companies that go public like Life360.
Is there a dissonance between the two?
Is there what? Sorry.
A dissonance. A clear distinction.
Because it sounds like two different worlds.
Yeah, it's true.
Actually, I do a little context switching.
But, really the underlying thread
that connects it all is
I just love helping entrepreneurs, right?
So, I found early on in my career
that I'm okay as a CEO.
I can run the company,
but I'm actually better at supporting CEOs.
Supporting entrepreneurs running companies.
So, really, when it comes to
when you think about value creation
and entrepreneurship and VC,
back scalable startups,
often at some point you'd either
think about fund raising, right?
To basically accelerate
scaling up the business.
Or you'd think about potentially
acquiring other companies
that can help you do that even faster
just getting the business.
Or you'd think about going public
or selling your company.
And those are places where I think
if you got a lot of collective experience
across different pieces
that add up to the startup ecosystem.
Whether it's product marketing,
technology and of course,
adding finance on top of that.
You can really add a lot of value
when you've got this
positive view of of things.
And that's really what I bring to the table.
Because of my background
being engineering product,
hands-on operations,
business development,
and also funding and finance.
Okay. So, if you had to guess,
how many entrepreneurs have you helped
over the years?
Honestly, probably hundreds.
By the way, I have a rule
which I'd like to share with you
and the audience.
Whenever I engage with entrepreneurs,
I just have so much sympathy
for what they're going through.
Because I've done it myself.
And I just try to find a way to help.
Even if it's one small thing
I make promise
to the public that I talk with.
If you're spending your time with me,
you're very valuable.
That I find at least one way to help you
and hopefully more.
But, you can't be with every entrepreneur.
I mean, your time is incredibly valuable,
incredibly scarce.
So, how do you choose
who do you work with and
who do you not work with?
That's a great question.
So, unfortunately, like other VCs,
I do have to filter out so I can focus
on what I think are opportunities
that have the highest propensity
or biggest chances to make an impact
on me as an investor.
And of course, on the founders
and on society, right?
So, I've got to pick and choose
which battles I want to fight.
And I do that using the skills
that I've learned as an institutional VC
from some of the best in the business
when they're working more in their ventures.
I learn how they evaluate opportunities
and I try to focus my time
on what I believe is the best way.
With that said, I think in this business,
in venture capital, you really have to
create value for people around you
in your network.
You've got to make an impact also
for your companies.
So, I try to do the best that I can
and free up as much time as I can.
Match to free up,
to really help people in my network.
Of course. Okay.
So, hundreds of entrepreneurs
that you've helped.
Are there more similarities
or differences that you've seen?
Because then obviously everybody's crazy.
That's like the number one similarity.
But more tangibly, are there more
differences or similarities?
It's funny that you say most
entrepreneurs are crazy.
I actually think the best entrepreneurs
are amazing in mitigating risk.
Because startups are so risky
to begin with.
That really a lot of good founders,
what they know how to do well, is like,
Okay, we've got those 10 different
risk vectors in our business.
How do we reduce it down to one? Right?
Because startups are so risky.
So, I think I've seen a lot of
different entrepreneurs
and they also invest in entrepreneurs
out here in the Bay Area.
And entrepreneurs across the US
with some focus on Israeli entrepreneurs.
Probably 30, 35%.
My portfolio is what I call
Israeli companies
which typically means that
they've been started by an
Israeli entrepreneur here in the U.S..
Is there a specific reason
for that by the way?
Why that focus?
Well, first of all, I'm Israeli.
And I moved to the states
a little bit over 10 years ago.
So, naturally, culturally, it's easier
for me to relate to Israelis, right?
And also because I believe
in the Israeli startup ecosystem.
I think we're just getting started, right?
With Israelis back in Israel
doing amazing work across different fields,
machine learning, cybersecurity,
so on and so forth.
There's so much more opportunities
back in our holy land.
That's one.
And second thing, I've seen
and I've worked with so many
successful, resourceful, creative,
amazing entrepreneurs.
Israelis moved here in the US.
So, I think it's actually an advantage
that I'm pretty easily able to tap
into Israeli entrepreneurs
and help them scale their companies.
Incredible. And I mean, you are very active
with both UpWest Labs and J-Ventures.
And I'm probably missing a bunch others
that are very involved with the Israeli
or Jewish ecosystem.
So, that definitely shows.
Scaling a startup.
You mentioned that a lot of entrepreneurs
are saying that they're able to mitigate
the risk or the various risks that they have.
But at the end of the day,
like 99.99% of startups fail.
So, what do you see that you're seeing
a lot of early stage entrepreneurs coming in
before even a pre-seed or a seed?
I mean, most of them are gonna fail.
What is the distinction that you see?
What are the common themes of those
that end up able to raise that capital
that gets them to where they need
to get to or don't?
That's a great question.
So, there's no science here, right?
There is directional thinking on what
me personally and other folks
in the industry believe that works.
So, I think in the early stages,
there's three things that I really
wanna focus on,
which is the quality of the team
and how fit is that team to solve
this specific problem.
TAM, total addressable market.
Which is a huge deal for VCs.
And it should be a huge deal
for entrepreneurs as well,
because you don't wanna go after
a small opportunity
that's not necessarily VC scalable
and trying to win that way
with all you can.
So TAM is I think a really important one
that entrepreneurs sometimes miss
and should pay more attention to.
And the last I would say,
which is not always easy for investors
to speak up and talk about that
is why they call Fundability.
So, you know how you sometimes
it's really hard to turn down
source reactions.
There's something there, right?
If you wanna succeed in the
VC start up game,
you've gotta be fundable.
And on top of all the other things
that I think about
when I think about investing
in pre-seen and seed companies,
I really do have to take into account
whether this people, this company,
this story would be able to scale
to more and more investors
that would put bigger checks
into the company's scale.
So, what you're saying is that
as an early stage investor,
you're looking at a company
that you're not just saying,
is this company able to use my money
wisely to get to a product or
to get to their first customers?
But are they able to then use
that momentum and raise
their series A, their series B
from institutional investors?
And which is one of the biggest tests, right,
for startups.
Are they're able to get past that big
first institutional funding
and propel that growth?
And I think having that funding
and having better and smarter people
are on the table to help you
as an entrepreneur.
Scale your startup is extremely important.
Which is why, also for me, as a VC,
I believe that's where VCs
can add most value.
Make sure that your companies
are well funded.
That's probably the single thing
that VCs can do to help
their entrepreneurs most.
Of course, there's many other things.
But that would be the first.
Yeah, I just had a fascinating
conversation with also somebody
from J-Ventures who's really well known
for crisis management and coming into
companies who need help
when they're not able to necessarily
raise another round and maximize
the value of their assets.
And one of the things that he mentioned
is that the real value
that the board members and the VCs
can provide is grounding the founders
and making sure that they understand
in the high level of what they need to do,
what how much funding they need,
how do they raise that funding
and make sure that their product,
that their company lives on.
What's happening today
in terms of raising money?
Because as a young entrepreneur,
it's very confusing.
A lot of people are saying,
only raise how much you really need.
Save the equity.
Focus on the business.
Don't focus on your ego.
A lot of others are saying,
raise as much as you can
because we don't know
what's happening tomorrow.
There might to be such a thing as covid-19
and you're not gonna be able to raise
that funding from March until May.
So, where are you on the spectrum of thought?
I'm very entrepreneurial friendly.
So, I'd probably say,
raise as much as you can,
but not too much.
Okay. So, explain that.
I think having more capital to work with
and basically enabling you
to have more room for mistakes.
And a lot of startups, I mean,
startups are really this journey
inside the founder
and the founding teams have.
Like, how quickly do you understand
how to position
your market, your product.
How to brand and sell
and operate and scale your business.
And it's really that journey
where you have to learn all those things
is the more that you do it,
the more value create,
the faster you create that value.
So, having more capital enables you
to potentially accelerate that journey.
And that's, of course,
is extremely important.
But on the other hand,
having too much capital
and we've seen some of this with some
of the Softbank vision funds,
where we've seen the situations of
over capitalization that basically
leads to mistakes, right?
Because it's easy
to solve problems with money.
But often that is not the right solution
for problems.
Often maybe you have
the wrong team members.
Or you've got the wrong business model.
Or maybe you've got
the wrong go-to market, right?
And pouring more money
on that problem actually doesn't fix it
and masks the real underlying issue.
So, raise as much money as you can
to give you as many bullets in that gun
to shoot and aim and try to hit your target.
But not too much that
you can become undisciplined.
I think that's fascinating.
This idea that money
can solve a lot of problems,
especially early on.
And it's almost blind the organization
into thinking into masking some of the real
underlying problems, because at the end,
you wanna be lean,
you wanna be efficient,
you wanna maximize your product
and not just use money to,
let's say I wanna get to
a million views on this show.
I can pay a million dollars
for advertising to get a million viewers.
But it doesn't necessarily mean
that my product is good or
that I'm doing something useful.
That's not a business.
You actually lost money.
That's not good business.
That's definitely not good business.
But if I'm able to do this with a $100
then we know that there's something here
that with a million dollars,
I can actually scale this
in a very healthy way.
Right. When you think about it,
a lot of VCs these days
they're really focused on scaling up.
It means that there is already
some level of product market
and maybe it's really good.
And right you need the majority
of capital is when
you're really scaling up.
Going from five salespeople
to 50 salespeople.
That requires investment ahead of time.
If you really hire those people.
Train them, make them effective, right?
If you're early on the first innings
of coming up with your company.
Whether it's a B2C or a B2B company,
I'd actually say it's not about the money.
It's about really coming up
with your thesis,
having an MVP,
getting out there testing stuff.
You don't need 100 people
and tens of thousands of dollars
to be able to do that.
To get that motivation.
Sure. So, I mean, you've seen
quite a few entrepreneurs go in
and scale their product
or scale their business
from five salespeople to 50 salespeople.
Well, what are the factors that are gonna
make or break you?
Or what do I need
to keep in mind later on?
This is a very selfish advice
that I'm asking for now.
What do I need to keep in mind
as young entrepreneur as
I will attempt to scale my business
from five customers to 50 customers?
That's a very interesting question.
So, I've got a little bit of a theory
that I've developed over the years,
and that is what got you here
is not necessarily
what's gonna get you there.
And more specifically, with startups,
what happens is that the culture
shifts a lot in the early stages, right?
So, early on it's like two gals and a dog.
Right? Sitting in some basement maybe.
And they're trying to come up
with something and come up
with a business plan.
And that scales all the way to
five, 10, 20 people.
But, once you get to forward is like,
managers and people reporting to them,
let's say a 20 to 30 people range,
something breaks,
something changes with the culture.
The lines of communication become longer
and more complicated in seeking
and getting alignment within the team
takes more energy.
And that's fine.
So, that's that breaking point.
There's another breaking point,
somewhere between those
50 to 80 employee range where, again,
you've got even longer lines
of communication.
Things are more complicated.
Some you have 20 people meetings
where everybody else is not there
has to say, "Yeah, this is awesome."
And then you can get going.
So, that's another breaking point.
And there's typically another one
of the 120 to 150 employee range.
And then you're like a big company.
You've got other company problems.
So, one of the things
that entrepreneurs and even investors
sometimes fail to recognize is that
the same set of people
that they've actually gotten from,
like 10 employees, zero employees to 20.
I think these are gonna be the people
that get you from 20 to 60.
It requires a different
type of leadership.
And you have to, first of all,
on yourself as an entrepreneur
and on your team and who's really
the best person for the job
at those different stages.
And that's something that's not always
easy for entrepreneurs to do
as the business scales up.
I mean, I've heard of this quite a few times.
There are there are some points
and I believe me,
Micha Kaufman from Fiverr,
he gave an inspiring talk on one
of the conferences I attended.
And he mentioned that
at every junction of Fiverr,
he kept asking himself,
"Am I still the right CEO
to grow this company?"
Now that we're hundreds of thousands
of employees.
This is a different company than
when we were a couple of friends
in a garage and just starting out.
And it sounds like it's almost
an impossible ask to go to an entrepreneur
or a founder and say,
"Hey, can you please ask yourself,
are you still the right CEO to run this?"
"And if not, can you please be honest
and go to the side
and let somebody else lead us?"
And Micha is amazing.
I love Micha.
He's one of those people that,
it's like it's the investors dream
of somebody who can start
by himself and then manage
a thousand people after an IPO, right?
There's people like that,
but it's not everybody.
And you have to really reflect
on yourself and understand.
I mean, even for me, it was a journey.
When I was younger, I was like,
"Yeah, I'll be CEO
and I'll be the best CEO ever."
And you know? That's not actually true.
Over time, you learn what you're good at.
And I'm really good at supporting
entrepreneurs first than being
an entrepreneur myself.
So, I think that kind of self reflection
can really go a long way for entrepreneurs.
Incredible. Itamar, what are you
passionate about?
What industries?
What type of entrepreneur?
What's it really gets you out of bed
in the morning?
So, I'm actually more of a generalist.
To be honest with you, I do have specific
areas and things that I focus on.
I invest in consumer technologies.
but not like e-commerce and media,
more services on the consumer side.
I invest in data and machine learning
tools and capabilities all the way across
the stack from infrastructure, deploying,
developing different types of data
and machine learning services
to actually service in financial services
and real estate and other verticals
where you can use data to disrupt
antiquated businesses.
And then I also do a little bit of
emerging tech, right?
Where I've tap them in stuff like mobility,
for example, IOT and other areas.
And it's interesting because when I look
at my track record of success rate,
my biggest wins as an investor,
Life360 IPO, credible IPO,
RING sold to Amazon
for over a billion dollars, right?
Automatic sold to SiriusXM.
When I think about
some of those opportunities,
They weren't thesis driven.
I recognize a strong entrepreneur
pursuing a great opportunity
and learn and adopted in the process of
engaging with them and build my thesis
on the go when I did that.
That's worked really well for me.
Right. That's inspiring.
Itamar, one thing I have to ask.
Entrepreneurship, a lot of times as a founder,
it seems you get a lot of nose.
You get a lot of suspicion.
You get a lot of rejections, right?
For every 99 VCs that say, "No."
Or, for every one VCs that says, "Yes."
You might get 99 that's say, "No."
How can founders get to be really open
to really important advice,
or be mindful of this advice
when they're constantly
hearing rejections and No's.
How can entrepreneurs filter out
the good and the bad
and really take in the important stuff?
Yeah, I think that's a great question.
And when I think about CEOs
and start companies,
tech startup companies,
they have two jobs that matter most to me:
one is fund raising
and the other one is creating a vision
for the company that aligns everybody,
every stakeholder in the company.
Those are the two most important things.
And I think if you're not really,
if you're not the right person to raise
capital from investors,
then I think in the early stages
you probably shouldn't be the CEO, right?
Because that's something
that the CEO is expected to do.
Like your team is coming in.
So, it's a little bit saliency,
to be honest with you.
Like, you have to reach out to all people.
It's a process like a sales process, right?
It's a partnership custom.
You're looking for a funding partner
for you on this journey.
And getting no's is really important.
And learning from those no's actually
getting valuable feedback,
finding ways to get valuable feedback,
finding ways to keep engaging
with someone, with investors.
Who knows, maybe it hasn't worked
this time around,
but it will work next time around, right?
That could be great.
And elegantly being able to
build your investors network,
even through those no's is actually
pretty critical for a startup CEO.
One way that I always chat about
with my entrepreneurs is,
often VCs would give you very vague
answers and why they chose
not to invest in your company.
And I think your goal as an entrepreneur
is to try to get to the bottom
of what's happening,
even if it's not something that's
comfortable for you to hear, right?
One of the best ways of doing that
is really [--]
and starting back to those VCs
to the people that introduced you to them
and trying to understand if you can
get some more information there.
Another good way
that I sometimes recommend is,
it's actually pretty good
if you've got two founders
in the meeting with VCs
where one, the CEO is just talking
because they're the ones that really meeting.
But another one
could be in the background.
So, the more taking notes
and just looking at people's reaction.
I love that.
Like,  what resonates?
What doesn't resonate?
It's really a different mindset
because you're not pitching.
You're there to really read
the reactions in the room.
And I've seen that being
successful as well.
I love that so much.
Itamar, right before we leave,
I can't believe 20 minutes are almost over.
This always go by way too fast.
I need three words that
you would use to describe yourself.
Can I use three words in one emotion?
100%
Okay. So, I Helping Entrepreneurs.
I love it. I love it.
And when you send me that emoji
through the e-mail,
it even looked better,
but it was much cuter
when you did it in person.
So, thank you.
Love helping entrepreneurs.
I look forward to reaching out
as an entrepreneur myself
to get some really important advice
and sending you my slidecks.
So, I just love that we're
forming this relationship.
And thank you for all the inspiring work
that you're teaching me
through a J-Ventures.
And thank you for being so generous
with your time here.
Absolutely. Thanks for doing this
great initiative.
I'm really excited about
what you're doing.
Red leaders all around.
And thanks for having me, Michael.
Thank you very much. Toda raba.
Stay safe out there.